ideas no one will know
all right
[Music]
you should not be speaking
yeah
me and my family just over the past two
years
literally just over the past few years
we need to clarify that because there's
people out there for connecting to
celebrate
they're United with everyone they go to
Every measure yeah
foreign
because
and you know you know sometimes people
don't want to become known and they've
noticed that if I'm if I'm with these
brothers I'm gonna become known I have
to leave them and so anyway this mama
left us and it was a message in one of
the East London well it's not it's
Southeast yes like a bullish idea
because I measured advising
everyone he said no no no they allow me
to speak okay for nearly two years or
three years nothing changed rather they
keep bringing people who are known to
misguided after him speak out against
them
so basically you're just looking for a
platform but you try to hide between the
Festival of the ulama you're allowed to
go to a measured by the truth
we have our platforms whoever wants us
comes to us yes I can't speak at school
I never could speak his formula it's
open platform it doesn't bring to no one
understand the street because open
platform but if I'm gonna go Ula and
many people ask me
but I want to know who you are does it
mean because I doubt you but we are now
out of the king of fan that was back
then oh my divided you understand let
alone our time there's many Goods many
Sexes so I don't know who you are I
don't wanna come and just use me you
understand all right so whilst people
are doing this you know what's happening
now some brothers they want to use have
a massage to become famous
you know I was speaking to one brother
now what's happening after which social
media
speakers
you know but you know now
if anyone speaks too
and I will not blame these brothers
because maybe I don't know I'll leave
the message that they welcome them okay
okay this papa is playing music yes he's
famous he stops
then it's natural by his lifestyle we
actually invited to message you to teach
and you have to go through something
like that
I'm speaking to you
understand but the problem is with you
maybe he's his kid but sometimes if a
psychologist will tell you psychology
say to you if someone is like to be
known then what he will do if he's going
to shift something else he will make
sure that something else is Shifting
through is something we're giving the
same thing that he had before which is
yeah you won't do that you understand
that's why even some brothers some
Rivers when they become Muslims it is
famous before then he will start doing
double
no control yourself what's the same
level as Cloud yes
it's a big sister you know I'm
[Music]
people praising you
advice to me first and to my beloved
brothers who are famous online that is
not proof
back okay
look at you dawa is foreign
[Laughter]
nothing
foreign
the mission
I said look
we would expect everyone to become
scorers but we want to sell a fear of
spread up
that every person must learn it and
there's a knowledge not everyone has to
learn it in some Muslims learn it it's
enough let me give you example how to
pray this knowledge is composure upon
every Muslim who reached hpbc and
Hussain
how to conduct marriage service is not
composure for all of us or other so now
knowledge the Earth to actually learned
is so he
the prayer knowledge you cannot say ah
shamsi knows how to pray
Muhammad no you need to learn it because
Allah sentimental and Allah will ask you
individually yes likewise when it comes
to Four Sisters about the Menses she has
to learn the ruling you know if she
reached the age she has she's going to
say my mother knows it because this type
of knowledge and there's some knowledge
is not composure upon me now but if I'm
gonna do it in the future we can
compulsory for example doing business if
I'm a businessman not I start doing
business then I need to learn
the rule of business so my advice to my
brothers and sisters everywhere learn
study seek knowledge don't just be like
I said I said that you know what
happened on social media we have many
storytellers you know literally you can
be sitting in front of this brother for
10 years you will never come to learn
how to pray correctly just stories yes
and so we have to learn we have spread
the question he uh to what is a shirk
the pillars of prayer the conditions of
prayer the obligations of prayer the
nullifies of prayer the conditions of
voodoo the obligation of the voodoo you
have to learn
safe sex
foreign
summarize
but with expressions
someone give me a gift someday